[Music]
and welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys we are off
the record featuring kat over here hello
hey
hi cats
them careful them we got if we had
careful boys merch would you wear it
yeah absolutely we wouldn't see we
wouldn't wear it we wouldn't wear it
we wouldn't support our own [ __ ] it's a
question we ask all of our guests
we're going to wear something that we're
apartments yeah who it's from where it
like i just i love free march what's
your favorite which i will wear too
what's your favorite piece of merch that
your friend is giving you my favorite
piece of merch is probably joe coy
sweater
are you going to come out with merch
really cool piece of free merch yeah joe
coy every single time he came on uh
finding the kid he would have a jacket
for me almost like he's my uncle
visiting me i was like hi here you go i
got a merch idea for you sweet very
sweet you i got a merch idea for you
socks so these are your feet right
imagine your feet okay toes though
individual toes okay this is going to be
on the t-shirt where your boobies are
but it's feet right yeah and then and
it's going to be they're going to be
kissing each other like this that's so
good yeah oh you got to make a face i'll
draw a face right here but they're
blurred and they they kiss it oh that's
good yeah they got to be blurry i got a
pitch yeah
pitch run okay
we take pictures of your feet yeah kind
of old hat we yeah yeah
we print those onto socks and you sell
those now everyone gets to wear your
feet with grips you sell them as mittens
that is genius oh that's why i pitch
ideas and then you guys make them better
and now it's a whole new meaning to like
a hand job or a foot job oh
versatile
so you're you're employing the sock
mittens
yeah you gotta you put them in the use
you gotta put them to work so how was el
salvador nick yeah um it was great how's
beautiful were you there i was there for
eight days was it your first time out of
the country
well no this is the first time since the
pandemic yeah and you were there working
right yeah i was there working
you're cleaning toilets yeah i was there
selling some merch over there but um
i my wife's family is from el salvador
so we went with my mother-in-law and my
wife and we went over there to go hang
out with family and meet some new family
is she related to the ms-13s that i've
seen documentaries about in el salvador
she is not and i was disappointed oh i
was very disappointed and i was hoping
you know i'd get some strength to get
some merch yeah i want some ms-13 and
this 13 merch would hit wait maybe a
little face tap while i was out there
but apparently according to the locals
they're all in jail they're all in jail
or they're in hiding because the
presidente made an example of uh the
gang members and the crime how do you
make an example of them well he put him
like there's i was telling joe about
this i guess there's these documentaries
about like they go to el salvador
prisons and they have them in like these
tiny little cages like these chicken
coops and they're like naked and they're
sitting like nuts to butts with each
other oh geez so it's like human
centipede [ __ ] or or it's just like a
regular chicken farm in america yeah but
like they're all cramped in these little
cages i don't i haven't watched the
documentary but this is just from my
understanding from what i've heard so
i'm probably wrong so don't quote me on
that that's how we report the news here
exactly
i'm probably wrong i wish the news said
that yeah yeah because they're usually
probably wrong they're always probably
wrong the most right thing they ever
said
but according to some of the locals that
we talked to they're saying like yeah
like they're just they they're they're
the president is really trying to hammer
down on this stuff so they could allow
more tourism more people to come in the
country and you know on top of that it
just it's
like we were in kind of like a smaller
rural town most of the time called son
sonate or something like that
in the middle of it you know there there
is one next to the uh like the mayan
ruins over there
what's this it's it's like a natural
body of water yeah that like usually
it's like it's like a cave water that
connects to the ocean but underground so
oftentimes like you'll see like the
instagram honeys like diving into like
yeah underground water pools
i like instagram honeysuckle you don't
talk about this i went to i was recently
in mexico i went to the fairmont maya
club i thought that [ __ ] was deluxe as
[ __ ] once a couple of cenotes my first
time i was like i'm gonna go [ __ ]
take some photos from instagram huh
and this [ __ ] was just like raging water
there's just like a million you know uh
city there yeah stoke
hey but but in like tulum in like cancun
their water parks [ __ ] all over american
water park really it's so crazy yeah
yeah
one that had um what do you call those
zip lines yeah but the zip lines crash
into the water
i think i know what you're talking about
out there
and then they do everything faster i
think it's crazier other countries they
don't do this whole like shoe everybody
yeah that's what kills that's what kills
all the fun in america because it's run
by cartels they probably die but that's
the fun it's like hey my son died i'm
not blaming you guys necessarily he
definitely should have worn the helmet
all the way
all good you should have buckled it
we'll take that off he's a thrill seeker
wanted to go on a really thin cable
slide a thousand feet at a hundred miles
an hour that's what's happening not a
big deal it happens god bless you the
water parks you could put on a hammock
right there's a [ __ ] hammock you sit
on the hammock no seat belt nothing and
then that [ __ ] [ __ ] slides you down
the zip line and then it crashes into
water and you're getting dragged in the
water with the hammock and you're like
whoa
it was so sick so sad no seat belts doc
dude
it's like an attitude era i miss a good
hard dashboard it's a real hard one
and let me tell you this the best part
of all
it includes a all-you-can-eat buffet
okay
and it's only a hundred bucks
for everything like 100 peso bucks or
like 100 bucks kind of a lot
i'm out i'm extinct no
no the whole thing you paid 100 to ride
a hammock until a water no it's a theme
park goddammit i just got wrecked one of
the attractions
what was the most exciting thing you did
in el salvador you know it wasn't okay
i'll say this this is gonna be kind of
corny but it's like meeting the whole
family wack is lame
but like because you know it's stories
i've heard of and so you plowed one of
the cousins nah dude good lord you like
that
that's wild family oriented son of a
[ __ ] that's crazy imagine just having
stoke city all around you yeah with your
cousin you're like i could probably rail
this [ __ ] right now that's just what
you're trying to do i'm not i'm not so
excited dude
i'm just a normal guy we're just normal
people we're all we're humans stop
looking at that cat like this while
you're sitting happy
i'm not a sex haver like anthony
she's human are you a sex haver she's a
kid i'm not really really no yeah he's
mr nikki limo green that's right and i'm
mr you know tiffany dunn
garcia
[Laughter]
we all do together as friends right and
how's that going so so it's blast so you
went to so you went and met like her
whole family like did they have a big
party nah it was like uh
it was mostly family on her mom's side
that i got to meet right and it was just
like a couple cousins here and there
mostly boys all right you're looking at
a cat like that dude don't [ __ ] get
all crazy direction while you wink did
you say that being there they were the
people were pretty amazed that you were
asian oh yeah i was telling you guys
that because they give you a quinceacino
no they didn't oh thank you and i wish
and i was a little disappointed that
they didn't have that and i was kind of
insulted frankly but uh in the area that
we ran called son sonate there it was
very evident that like tourists don't go
there at all like it's a purely just
local town
so when we're walking around their
mercados which means like market you
know people
you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ] tourist
that goes to a different country like
actually you say it like mercado the
accent's over the sea thank you no he's
like we were at this little [ __ ]
have you studied
we're all eating chicken today at lunch
and he's like oh this isn't quite like
i'll stop with the word
this isn't it
polo
you son of a [ __ ] yeah i am that guy
but when we went over there it was like
people were turning their heads because
they were like yo this is a real life
chinese person anyway they recognize
when you walk by where they're like
there he is the legend is true the
[ __ ] is here did you kind of talk
more chinese
yeah i made my eyes even smaller like
why are you doing with their eyes
but we were walking around everybody was
kind of like turning heads like oh [ __ ]
as a real chinese person one of our
cousins she watches
um like a a little girl a little baby
she babysits her and this little girl is
really into bts
and i thought you could say she watches
just kidding news and i was like
no [ __ ] way she does yeah those
people do not have time to watch [ __ ]
jay candies
and she's a big fan of
bts and
the cousin was like i'm gonna meet a
chinito today
is like you know that connection's so
funny yeah and then and then the little
girl yes out there paving the way for
nick
the little girl was like such a big bts
fan she was like oh
oh my god you're going to meet a chinese
come i'll be i'll be good i swear like
can i just go so it's like you imagine
like a ghostly white korean
and then she meets this [ __ ] and she's
like that's not chinito like we're like
you're dark refugee
he's big his hair's short his ears are
funny he's dark and he's not singing
yeah yeah yeah why aren't his ears this
big
how can't he do that you're fatigued
he's speaking with a love voice and i
have like a really deep or i was like oh
thank you if i did that i think i would
have gotten no you you should have been
like
oh yeah were you wearing barbell merch
too
no not a suit or nothing i was bts i was
just wearing regular like shorts and
just tank tops
or lizards
no no [ __ ] way dude i'll support that
kind of action over here that cat like
that dude
wait who was who was the the lady that
was showing off to the kid that she's
gonna meet a chinese man oh yeah that
was my uh
my wife's cousin oh
and they were out there just like oh
yeah like i'm just walking around nick
hey you guys want to meet some chinitos
50 pesos five bucks five bucks he's like
the [ __ ] show-and-tell for the
village he's like oh step right five
bucks
we have a
you want to chinese this chinese guy in
the nuts did you live up to the hype for
her i don't think so we didn't meet i
didn't did you become the talk of the
town for being uh a chinese emperor ten
bucks you see his little dick come on
it's really small i swear
uh nah i it just people were like
looking like oh [ __ ] that's crazy and
they would just go along their day
everybody was really nice they just they
just stare at you they just they would
just go like oh [ __ ] all right and then
just keep going but everyone was really
nice but it also could be like they were
probably looking at my deformed ears
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
they're like chinese people have weird
ears yeah yeah it's a new stereotype
they're different on television but i'm
telling you everybody was so freaking
nice unlike sometimes uh when i went to
i think i told a story where i went to
uh
tulum
like probably two three years ago and i
had like a lot of people kind of like
[ __ ] with me like while i was there like
local rock covered there dude
that was both
pre-coping yeah play out of the car
yeah
play the carpet boom had a lot of chill
people they don't hawk as hard yeah but
they play the carmen there's always like
hey [ __ ] chicken buy this [ __ ] right
now you want a drink [ __ ] and i
think it's because it's like the really
tourist areas the tourist areas are just
like there's a different vine while
karma's got the [ __ ] of the uh cabana
thing right back dude
coco bongo dude we stayed at a hotel
right next door we couldn't [ __ ]
sleep because it was just yeah he was at
a hotel recently next to the cocoa bongo
too and i was like you know what is this
the really legendary the masked cocoa
bongo i'd do research on it was it and
apparently no the mask had come out just
before that and i think according to one
article that reads i don't know it's
true but jim carrey owns the cocoa bongo
in uh implied no karma wow shout out to
jim carrey but while i was replying to
carmen people like i there was there was
a time there was like three local dudes
walking by me with my girl and they they
they like got my face and went like hola
and they just like walked by and i was
like yo what the [ __ ] is going on here
so people were like [ __ ] with me they're
like pointing at me like chinito and
they started laughing to me to me it's
more wild that like crazy they're just
like you know police that are just
driving down the street up and down
there's people and everybody's got like
[ __ ] rifles and stuff and there's
like 20 of them yeah everyone's fully
militarized so you're just a [ __ ]
truck that's how it was like it wasn't
like that too crazy in el salvador but
there were
there were like guards and military
policemen everywhere
but like with like crazy ars and they
were actually very nice they were just
like hey welcome like they're just like
it was just very welcoming across the
board that was my favorite thing to do
is when i would like ride in mexico is
like whenever i see a caravan of all
those [ __ ] military dudes
and they wait back do their job
and they start shooting the sky you can
honk it yeah it would be so sick that
would be
don't all bullets that go up also come
down no no no they just go over the
clouds they go in the closet
they're just going to space yeah yeah
aliens are dying at the [ __ ] hundreds
now that you know all these stuff about
el salvador would you be going back on a
regular oh yeah i think we're gonna go
probably back like every year can i tag
along yeah let's go you think we you you
can make like a uh get like a i don't
know a supplier relationship out there
then
i don't know probably
people are always there if you're gonna
go all the time all we gotta do is
figure out who the eisen sells planes at
like retail prices yeah we need that
pair though you have to have that pair
yeah otherwise nobody's gonna be able to
do that i don't think el salvador was
known for drug plane training they're
not really not nobody said drugs yeah
whoa whoa whoa
buy the drugs first before you buy the
plane come on man it's my business plan
oh you don't go direct to the source
but the beaches are beautiful everyone's
really nice we should all go don't call
them beaches dude they're women if i'm
gonna call
a woman
a [ __ ] i'm just gonna call him a [ __ ]
am i right
i don't know why
why did i do that this guy's gonna
destroy my life just destroyed my life
believe women oh dude mosquito it was a
zika situation there your boy was
getting eaten alive believable [ __ ]
don't miss them and living in vegas so
get diarrhea from drinking water or
anything you know what it's funny i
didn't really get diarrhea out there but
as soon as i came back i got diarrhea
maybe you just always have it is the
water here trapped it may be maybe
that's what it is but like i'm fine i
didn't it wasn't really that bad out
there food was really good
um what was your least favorite
experience in el salvador you could say
it on camera
[ __ ] honestly it was just getting a koba
test out there and having to fly back to
the states with a positive wait we still
gotta we gotta do it it was stressful
yeah to get back in the country because
it's america yeah and it's stupid it's
like no one's checking you gotta do it
back in but in mexico they have no mass
policies they have no [ __ ] uh vaccine
policies none of that should they only
[ __ ] believe in kovid 50 so what
would have happened if you're positive
when you flew back i don't think they'll
let you on the plane you gotta stay
another two weeks and you guys stay in
like 10 days or something i had a body
get stuck in italy for that test
probably yeah exactly but that's the
positive in italy and he had to wait
like nine days to get on the plane oh
wow ironically the sound of getting
stuck in italy for nine days sounds fun
it does huh it does sound great not if
you go over budget
hotels
unless you're staying on the streets of
italy
yeah that's another still sounds kind of
fun well he got to go have actual
[ __ ] like olive garden in italy which
is great what not unlimited breath
breadsticks and salad yeah oh i know
what happened to me that was yeah he
went for the first ones
i was we went to this like i guess this
hotel and it was like an eco villa or
whatever so it's like eco-friendly i
don't know what that means but that's
what the name of it was and in the
bathroom it was it was outdoors and
there was these giant windows so you
like things can fly in so i was pooping
on our last night there
and this flying roach flew in
and that's traumatizing and you know
while you were taking the [ __ ] i was
taking a [ __ ] and it was like buzzing by
me and i was freaking out because i felt
vulnerable right i'm sitting on the
toilet what did you swat it away i was
trying to and i was robbing weave yeah i
was like
i was just kind of scared shadow boxing
yeah i smacked the [ __ ] out of it with
my shoe my crocs they saved lives wow
save lives and i smashed it takes less
time
just breathing heavy afterwards let the
adrenaline come down no you're just
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] my brains
but yeah that was pretty much it but
even like i was kind of anxious about
the flying roaches and the insects and
all that but it really wasn't that bad
because you realize like you're in the
[ __ ] jungle out here like is that
what it is it pretty much is like rain
forest so you just like expect it like
yeah
yeah the mosquitoes obviously suck
though they got to figure out a way to
get i don't like nah mosquitoes are
terrible because i was thinking about if
i wanted to go back to tulum and i was
like mosquito man
and we had sprays going to hawaii bro we
were spraying the shells yeah while we
don't like as a species try to eradicate
mosquitoes because because it's food for
something no no no actually they've done
scientific i've had there's no [ __ ]
there's no way i've hated mosquitoes so
hard that i've also googled this to know
if i was just thinking like genocidal
thoughts
yeah and and mosquitoes specifically if
eradicated from the entire podcast will
happen nothing will happen they they
serve no purpose but let's do it let's
do it yeah don't they help spread
disease
yeah they help population control yeah
oh
natural selection a little darwinism to
cook it up you know mosquitoes aren't
even supposed to be in polynesia
who did it
that colonies
yeah why people spread mosquitoes
because it can't it came on the boats
ugh thanks steve yeah we also spread
medicine so what do you think
what do i say about that you spread the
cure yeah [ __ ] you they brought the
mosquito and then they brought the cure
now you sold the go read under
candlelight then [ __ ] you're
welcome
it's time to start saying you're welcome
a little bit more yeah have you ever
read under candlelight it's awful thanks
benjamin you say that every night who
invented the candle i don't know
probably a white dude
i'm not sure i have no idea it's
actually the chinese the chinese
it's probably the chinese but then they
didn't use it like the white people did
how'd they use it i don't
chinese always embed everything don't be
like yeah we had gunpowder but it's like
you didn't use it in guns
what'd they use it for firecrackers
it's way better so it wasn't called gun
powers firecracker partner yeah
who invented sparklers americans
probably
on july 4th you're welcome [ __ ]
from the midwest spaghetti though
chinese people invented spaghetti
noodles noodles oh yeah
italians didn't have pasta no it was uh
the noodle came before the place yellers
yellers yellers who invented bitcoin
japanese man damn that son of a [ __ ]
huh you don't know that yet
god damn that son of a [ __ ]
isn't that just a cover remember
remember during the bull market when
everyone's like with satoshi a woman i'm
like yeah probably
oh my god
[Music]